The COVID-19 coronavirus
is still spreading.
But while one early study found
that 80% of cases are considered mild,
the definition of mild can
include a range of symptoms
and still be painful, even though cases
might not require hospitalization.
Rishi Desai: I have mild
symptoms, I'm coughing.
But am I coughing once every minute,
or is it every 10 minutes or five minutes?
And if that starts to get
more and more frequent,
let's say I'm coughing every two minutes,
now every one minute, and
now I can't even speak to you
because I'm running out of breath,
those are the things that would trigger
me picking up the phone and saying,
"Hey, you know what,
things are actually worse."
Narrator: That's Dr. Rishi Desai,
the chief medical officer at Osmosis.
He says fatigue is the most common symptom
of the coronavirus,
but there are some other
ones to watch out for.
Desai: So, typically, it slows you down.
It causes fatigue and malaise.
You might be less inclined
to get up and do work.
Maybe a sore throat,
so maybe some focal symptoms like that.
You can have a runny nose,
you can have some congestion in your nose.
That inflammation in your
nose makes it hard to smell.
It can also affect your
taste, so, all of a sudden,
things that you usually
would really enjoy,
you're not really enjoying
those foods anymore.
A lot of what I'm describing,
to be perfectly honest,
is a lot of the same
sort of general symptoms
or mild symptoms you get
with the common cold.
Narrator: Likewise, the way to mitigate
your mild coronavirus symptoms is largely
the same way you'd
relieve your typical cold.
Desai: For example, you
would drink a lot of fluids,
you'd make sure those fluids
have a little bit of salt
and a little bit of sugar
in them, because that way
you get the fluid absorbed into your body.
So, a great example of that
would be broth or soup.
You'd made sure in general you're hydrated
and that you're peeing
multiple times a day.
You'd monitor your fever
and see if the fever is
getting better or worse.
And if it's getting worse,
maybe you take a medication like Tylenol.
The one thing that's different
that you would do with COVID
is that you'd monitor your
symptoms really closely,
because if they're getting worse,
then you'd want to call
and make sure you get seen.
Narrator: The CDC says that
if you're experiencing symptoms
you think may be a result of COVID-19,
seek medical attention by
calling your doctor first.
If you have an underlying condition,
like diabetes, asthma,
cardiovascular disease, or cancer,
and you think you might have
contracted the coronavirus,
Desai says you should be seeking
medical attention immediately.
For those with mild symptoms,
it's extremely important to monitor them.
To prevent the spread of coronavirus,
do your best to limit contact with people.
Stay vigilant by washing your hands,
cleaning the surfaces you use daily,
and monitoring your health.